[Music]
it's been rumored and a lot of people
saying it's true that that Snooki is
pregnant when you're on a reality show
fans are talking about the real you and
you meet fans all the time that say to
you they want you to have a baby that's
gonna be a very strange thing when
people feel they know you that well and
then they say hey you should have a baby
I mean it is but I also it's like it's I
think it's sweet and we're honoring our
reality show and we open up our lives
every one I think it's sweet that people
want me to have a baby so badly but I've
been offered people have offered me
their body to be my surrogate like
strangers I'm like thanks not there yet
and I have no idea who you are
I've also people telling me that's
strange true that you're married and
people are saying and I'll be your
surrett you know two people told me
positions strangers like sex positions
oh if you do this this will guarantee
you have a boy and I'm like oh I don't
even know what's your name like they
will come up to me I don't know where
people people come out of the bushes and
say try this position and you'll have a
boy if they're saying that they live in
those bushes yeah I was actually at Bed
Bath and Beyond and I was in the store
and someone was like khlo
she said my name's so authority that I
was like Owen I must know this girl
right and she was like this is what you
ought to do just went straight into it
not like hi how are you my name is like
mine this is what you got to do
bla bla very graphic very gray and I was
like oh and I kind of looked around and
I looked down I was like her tag said my
name is whatever I when she worked at
Bed Bath & Beyond I was like are you
legally allowed to talk to me I think
it's a testament to that store that they
provide that level of service
I think it's yeah not only what we sell
you in the beyond beyond